i want to talk a little bit more about
you know athletes in this space you know
lou williams also raps have you ever
heard of his music yeah i heard louis
yeah for sure and one person who is
always posting ul's music online is
lebron james
how does that happen like how does
lebron become the guy that gets migos
music first i feel like he gets
everyone's music first but how does that
happen i feel like it's organic and then
if we're just feeling the vibe i know he
needs music just to sometimes need that
unreleased music because he in the lab
when nobody see it he in the lab when
everybody thinking that he on vacation
so same way with music we got songs we
got records in our phone well you might
think we doing a show we got another hit
ready to go so you just got to get them
geared up like that on some exclusive
time mm-hmm cause you know the joke is
he always posted but everyone's like
okay is he a music guy does he give you
good feedback
on your music most definitely i think so
for sure
he told me about that straight and then
when they got some straightening so like
i'm just like all right cool he know
that he know the objective you get the
point in it and i feel like
with music and sports i feel like we
need that fuel we you know saying it's
both is both organically like married
you know what i'm saying
like we we were they were a jury they
dressed like us to hit before they hit
the court you know saying we want to
hoop like them you know i'm saying we
make basketball rippers make bars and
everything i feel like um
just day lifestyle now i like that i go
together equally so i feel like just
music and them just go together so
taking their opinion really means
something yeah you know what i'm saying
so you send him straightening for sure
he says
don't not get straight about straight
that was the text that just said
understand
i swear to god and then you said
it's on yeah
and there was just an understanding of
of what that meant yeah